[Music]
on this wednesday night potential
threats to canada's vaccine supply
how india and the eu are putting their
own citizens
first i think there's a reason to be
concerned mounting anxiety over vaccine
nationalism
a new strategy to stretch doses why
covet survivors in quebec may get only
one shot
going nowhere fast she's jammed in there
pretty good
that enormous container ship stuck in
the suez canal
and the boy in the tent i'm proud
from doing it the 11 year old going all
out to raise money for charity
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with troubling new signs of
vaccine nationalism
and potential problems with our vaccine
supply as an increasing number of
countries grapple with the rise of new
variants
countries that produce covid19 vaccines
are moving to limit exports
they want to ensure their own citizens
get protected
first that leaves canada vulnerable
we're completely reliant in other
countries including
india canada is expecting 1.5 million
doses of the astrazeneca vaccine from
india in the next two months according
to reuters news india has decided to
temporarily halt
all major vaccine exports the european
union another major vaccine supplier to
canada is also
tightening its export rules all of this
leads to uncertainty about our vaccine
supply
in the weeks ahead abigail beeman has
our top story tonight
canada has received a quarter of the 2
million astrazeneca shots coming from
india
the rest expected in april and may
reuters now reports india is temporarily
halting exports
we have no indications that the 2
million doses we will be receiving from
the serum institute
over the coming two months will in any
way be affected
i think there's a reason to be concerned
we don't have all of the details yet and
we don't know
whether india or the eu are going to
take steps to prevent exports to canada
the european union just tightened export
controls
most of canada's vaccines are made in
europe we also need to ensure
vaccination of our
own population and there
indeed we are in a sense behind as a
schedule
behind schedule with canada further
behind the eu
the eu's new controls consider
reciprocity and proportionality
suggesting if canada outpaces the eu's
vaccination rates
we could be cut off if canada does
succeed they might be a victim of their
own success
if they are dependent primarily on
europe for vaccines which to a certain
extent they are
the uh you know the silver lining there
is that
the supply challenges in the eu
are likely short-term they've sent to
britain and they've got zero back
experts believe the eu controls are
largely aimed at the uk
to even up things with britain uk is not
a member of the family anymore
we are concerned with the new reports of
restrictions out of the eu or potential
restrictions out of the eu
and we will be continuing to work with
our counterparts uh including direct
contact uh from me to the highest levels
of the european commission
verbal don't worry everything's okay is
is not what
provinces or any canadians are looking
for from the federal government they're
looking for certainty
while the federal government says
they've been assured the eu's measures
won't affect shipments to canada
experts say nothing is certain yet with
some expecting vaccine nationalism to
get
worse before it gets better abigail
beeman global news
ottawa india holding astrazeneca
exports could be bad news for kovacs the
global initiative to get vaccines to
countries in need
dozens of lower income countries are
relying on the initiative to get
vaccines they otherwise would not be
able to afford
and the serum institute of india is one
of the key suppliers
according to reuters news it has already
supplied 17.7 million doses
kovacs organizers have said they are
expecting over a billion
doses well canada is making progress in
rolling out vaccine doses already in the
country
though there is still a lot of ground to
cover across the country today more than
146
000 doses were given more than 3.7
million canadians have now received at
least
one dose that works out to roughly 9.8
percent
of the population and in that group you
can now count two
former canadian prime ministers
jean-claude and joe clark
both got their first doses at a
community clinic
in ottawa well with more demand for
vaccine than supply provinces are coming
up with ways
to stretch the doses quebec is now
recommending that people who have
already had covid19 and recovered
should get only a single dose of the
vaccine
mike armstrong explains why
at this point in the pandemic
governments are looking for
any way to get more supply of vaccine or
to make the supply they've got
go further well to stretch what it has
quebec is changing
how many doses some people are given
the province's public health director
says if someone has already had covid19
and recovered they don't need a second
dose
now both pfizer and moderna call for two
doses of their vaccines
first shot and then a booster but there
are now studies that say
someone who's recovered from the novel
coronavirus already
has antibodies and that first shot acts
as a booster i'm surprised people
haven't moved to this faster
infectious diseases expert dr zane
chagla says the studies so far have been
quite clear
in fact they've shown people who've had
coven 19 actually have
more antibodies after one shot than
someone who's never had covet 19 but
who's had
two shots as a way of stretching
supplies not giving people a shot they
don't need
makes more than little sense it's an
easy win to save doses if we if we go
forward with the strategy
now governments around the world have
been cautious about fiddling with the
vaccine company's protocols but quebec's
not the first
italy announced earlier this month it
would be going with a single dose for
recovered patients france and spain did
the same in february
could other canadian provinces follow
suit well manitoba said wednesday it's
waiting for more information the data
right now
is still early and
not you know there's not very much of it
yet
there are some questions quebec still
hasn't answered if someone recovered say
six months ago would they still have
enough antibodies if someone had a mild
case would they have enough
some of that's still being worked out
quebec also hasn't said how many doses
it thinks it might save
but in a province that's had more than
three hundred thousand cases
it could be substantial mike armstrong
global news
montreal westjet will soon restore
service to parts of eastern canada
months after the airline suspended many
routes because of low demand
service will resume to fredericton
moncton charlottetown
sydney nova scotia and quebec city
beginning in late june
the airline will also restore flights
from saint john's to halifax
in may and from st john's to toronto in
june last fall's cuts resulted in
temporary layoffs of dozens of
staff in the region air canada will also
bring back
a limited number of flights to certain
sun destinations
starting in may there will be three
flights a week between toronto and
mexico city and
one flight a week to jamaica and
barbados those routes
were suspended in january at the request
of the federal government
companies and governments are all
looking to the future and ways to get
back to business as usual
ontario's finance minister tabled a new
budget today
billions is being budgeted for health
care and to stimulate the economy
travis danraj has details of what's in
this pandemic budget
and what's been left out travis donna
doug ford's progressive conservative
government promised to do
two things with this budget protect
lives and
livelihoods but many are already saying
the plan for recovery
falls short after a year in stormy seas
safe harbor is finally in sight
the message from ontario's finance
minister as he delivered a budget that
will attempt to weather the economic
storm
caused by covet 19. we are now in a race
against time vaccines versus variants
on that front a billion dollars to help
bolster the province-wide vaccine
rollout
much of the previously announced money
though has already been spent
2.3 billion more for testing and contact
tracing
a bold promise to provide the best
long-term care in canada
but few initiatives on that front this
after the horror stories we heard about
long-term care homes during covent
absolutely shocking that it seems once
again the ford government has forgotten
about long-term care
how can that possibly be mental health
is health period an additional 175
million dollar investment toward mental
health including a program that will
bring mobile clinics to rural
communities
and 12.5 million to support opp officers
struggling small business owners will be
pleased to hear they can now apply for a
second round of grant payments
up to a maximum of twenty thousand
dollars and while the grant goes up it
doesn't go up enough to deal with the
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
dollars
in debt that so many of our small
business owners are carrying
premier ford's government also striving
for balance
in 2029 lots of questions about how
realistic that is
and if it's possible to achieve without
tax hikes
now ontario's government also announcing
today the creation of a new task force
that will look into how best to support
populations
that have been disproportionately
affected by the pandemic
including young workers and women donna
all right travis danrosh at queen's park
in toronto thanks
there are new developments tonight in
the investigation into sexual misconduct
allegations in the canadian navy
defense minister harjit sajan has
requested a review after the navy shut
down an internal investigation without
speaking to all of the witnesses
at issue are alleged inappropriate jokes
made on a zoom video call
as our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson reports it strikes at the
heart of the problem the canadian armed
forces has grappled with for decades but
never eliminated and a warning some of
the content in this story
may be disturbing
the notorious red room from fifty shades
of gray
oh my god a pop culture reference to a
series of novels and movies about a
sado-masochistic relationship
involving sexual bondage which was at
the center of a navy investigation
into alleged sexual misconduct by senior
officers
regarding inappropriate sexualized
comments on a zoom call with over 132
sailors on it yesterday global news
learned the navy had shut the
investigation down
concluding it did not reveal that a
service offense was committed
the navy says they reached out to
everyone on the call
but only spoke to 54 people the
investigation concluded without all
complainants or witnesses being
interviewed
the investigation did not appear to
consider alleged additional
inappropriate comments
about kinky sex and bondage or whether
navy brass present
should have intervened the investigation
illustrates the problem when the
military
investigates itself it's really
highlighted the
flaws in the system the holes the
things that have allowed sexual
misconduct
to perseverate within the canadian armed
forces
navy officers who reached out to global
news were outraged by the advice they
were given following the investigation
which encouraged all ranks to publicly
challenge the brass
if they feel they hear comments that are
inappropriate saying
engage directly with the speaker no
matter how senior
so that they may clarify or apologize or
address the matter
former army officer leah west knows
herself how hard it is to confront a
superior officer publicly
it's really hard to speak up when you're
the target
of a joke that everyone around you is
laughing at
she says the advice shows deep cultural
problems in the military
and a failure to hold the brass
accountable instead she says
there is victim blaming because it
placed the responsibility for
accountability
on the junior person in the room
and the target of that misconduct
defense minister harjit sajin has asked
acting chief of the defense staff
general wayne ayer to review the navy's
findings
i learned of the conclusion of this
investigation leaked yesterday
and i have concerns experts say the
investigation shows the need for a
watchdog outside the chain of command
one that would perhaps report to
parliament but that's something
the defense minister still would not
commit to today
donna mercedes thanks traffic jam in the
suez canal coming up the latest on that
huge ship
stuck in the world's busiest shipping
route how did it happen
plus a frightening way to get moving on
a busy road the outcome of a dump truck
pushing a mini
and one prince two new jobs who just
hired
harry
this is an alarming way to get through
traffic a dump truck pushed a mini
cooper up
and on ramp and then along toronto's
gardener expressway for more than half a
kilometer
the truck driver stopped after being
flagged down by motorists and has been
charged with several driving and
commercial vehicle offenses
police say the driver of the mini was
lucky to suffer only minor injuries
this massive container ship could use a
push you've probably heard about the
ever given it turned sideways and got
stuck in the southern end of the suez
canal
the vital waterway that links the red
sea to the mediterranean
it's caused a big traffic jam of fully
loaded oil tankers and container ships
at both ends of that canal
all those ships can do now is sit and
wait and that's led
to a jump in oil prices today after a
dip yesterday
redmond shannon is tracking developments
tonight
stuck in the suez and going nowhere
the plight of the massive mv ever given
has the potential to play havoc with
trade between asia
and europe on tuesday morning the 400
meter long container ship
ran aground stubbing its bow into one
canal wall
its stern against the other effectively
becoming a lock
gate on one of the world's most
important trade routes
she's longer than the canal is wide and
and
so she's jammed in there pretty good and
so it's going to be very difficult to
to pull her off and be very careful
pulling her off because again
they've got all that weight in the
center of the vessel and she's not
buoyant right now because she's hung up
on the edge
the company that manages the ship says
it has ruled out a mechanical failure
the owner suspects sudden high winds are
to blame
the headache is perhaps best illustrated
from space
the blockage causing two ever-growing
swarms of vessels
at either end of the 200 kilometer suez
canal
50 vessels used the canal every day
among them
oil tankers going to and from the
persian gulf
the price of oil jumped sharply
wednesday after dropping on tuesday
that log jam is starting to grow as
every hour that passes so
it's a it's a really serious incident
you know if you think how fragile
it shows you how fragile the global
supply chains can be at time
and as as we rely on shipping to deliver
all that medical equipment the fuel the
food
the other supplies this is quite a
critical moment the longer this goes on
ships will have to decide if they want
to wait
or to go all the way around africa and
that adds
you know 3800 miles to journey in about
12 days for an average ship so
you can see that how important the
sewers canal is to
to minimize disruptions and to keep
trade flowing it's thought the process
of
freeing the ever given could still take
days redmond shannon global news
london still ahead canada sanctions
russia over the attempted murder of a
kremlin critic
canada is imposing new sanctions on nine
russian officials over what it calls
gross and systematic violations
of human rights two people in president
putin's inner circle
and the head of the russian security
service are included the diplomatic
pressure is a reaction to the attempted
assassination of opposition leader
alexei navalny who was poisoned with a
military-grade nerve agent
global affairs canada says the sanctions
are aimed at those
involved in the attempted murder of
alexei navalny his subsequent
prosecution
and the silencing of russian citizens
who protested his treatment
with heavy-handed and often violent
methods navalny is serving a two and a
half year sentence at a russian prison
camp
his allies say his health is
deteriorating they believe his life is
in danger in prison
his lawyer was unable to see him today
the valley supporters are organizing a
new
mass protest to demand his release
a seven-year-old girl in myanmar has
been killed when security forces opened
fire during a raid
on her family's home
she is the youngest victim of the
military crackdown on anti-coup
protests according to the charity save
the children at least 20 children have
now been killed since the military coup
began nearly two months ago
save the children says security forces
have shown a complete disregard for
human life
and have killed more than 260 people
across the country
weathering a year of storms next the kid
on a camp out campaign for charity
prince harry has a new job two jobs
actually the duke of sussex is joining
the aspen
institute's commission on information
disorder a six-month stint
setting misinformation in the u.s
looking for solutions to fake news and
media polarization
harry is also becoming the chief impact
officer at betterup a mental health and
coaching startup based in san francisco
that
harry says he's been using he says he
was matched with an awesome coach who
gave him sound advice
and a fresh perspective well an 11 year
old boy in the uk is giving everyone a
fresh perspective on generosity and
selflessness
max woozy has been raising money for a
hospice by sleeping in a tent for nearly
a year
it started as a tribute to his friend
and neighbor who died
now as crystal gamansing reports it's
grown into something bigger
than he ever expected max woozy is
living his
best 11 year old life no parents telling
him lights out
and loads of snacks the wind rain and
snow
he could do without there have been a
few nights where
i have been crying myself to sleep
because it's just been must of
soaking wet he's been the boy in the
tent for the past 12 months an out of
the box idea that's raised more than 260
thousand dollars canadian
for the north devon hospice a tribute to
his neighbor and friend
rick abbott before he died abbott gave
max his tent and made him
promise he'd have adventures
max's mom sleeps indoors
but not soundly you know the worst one
was i was sat up in bed at about
two o'clock in the morning googling
should you sleep outside in a tent in a
thunderstorm
because we had this huge storm going on
overhead
i was terrified that night but he kept
his cool
stuck with it and he is almost at his
goal of sleeping out for 365 days
leading to kudos from friends rugby
stars
even legendary adventurist bear grylls
you're gonna look back for all your life
think wow
i'm one of the only people in the world
to have done that i'm proud
from doing it so i kind of want to make
everyone else feel proud because
this year has well this year
sucks sucked indeed but max has a plan
a big campo where kids from all over can
join him on march
27th to mark his one-year milestone
so it's kind of our time to shine where
we can raise
money all together shine inspire
and have a little fun crystal gomencing
global news
london love it and that is global
national for this wednesday i'm donna
friesen tonight's era canada is greens
point lighthouse in
latite new brunswick there are beautiful
spots all over canada please email yours
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye
[Music]